my son he is dead and upon Powder River  there is a man trying to forget that he  ever existed  so I'm gonna go up there to remind him  don't expect me to care for one boy  [Music]  oh you'll have to  my people lived here over 2 000 years  white folk come like locusts hopping  over each other's bad to steal gland  I just need a few Acres  Revenge you ain't the only one  a David Wellman ain't exactly looking to  be found man how long are you traveling  with maybe it's best for you to see the  world as it really is us that I got a  knack for survival  nice country you're gonna win you can't  fight fair you wanna have some fun  foreign  [Music]  it was in the Stars  [Music]